and once we win the house
do we have a better speaker of the house
than mtg
look at that
that's amazing
are we going to need her as speaker of
the house to take it to the democrats
[Applause]
this morning there's a video of steve
bannon marjorie taylor green mike
lindell on the same screen at the same
stage speaking into microphones talk
about stupid holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and steve
bannon says out loud into a microphone
that when the republicans when the nazi
party of america first takes the house
back we're gonna make marjorie taylor
green
the speaker of the house did you need
another reason like another reason let's
just say you weren't quite there yet on
making sure to engage in your democracy
and i'm not just talking about voting i
tweeted this that if you need another
reason or you're still looking for one
here's a [ __ ] reason for you their
plan is to make marjorie taylor green
the speaker of the house that's that's
their plan that's steve bannon's plan
mike lindell seemed to like it too i
mean you know he likes anything that
puts fascist in control of stuff the
pillow nazi you know the my pillow nazi
but marjorie taylor green their plan is
to make her the speaker of the house so
what are you gonna do are you gonna sit
at home and go up democrats got this
slam dunk no problem and risk that steve
bannon will threaten violence against
members of the house republican members
of the house to make sure that they put
marjorie taylor green in charge of our
house our house of representatives you
don't think steve bannon will call for
for action if they don't make her the
speaker you don't think he's been
calling on all the moglodites to save
trump from this search and seizure of
classified documents that he stole but
steve bannon of course of course if they
win the house they will use threats
against our country
to direct them at republicans to do
their bidding they continue to do it and
we got them right where we want them but
we have to engage in our democracy and
there's no better excuse no better
excuse than steve bannon's great idea is
have marjorie taylor green as the
speaker of the house just the thought
just the thought of that absolutely
makes you want to [ __ ] puke
hey midas mighty emma silverman here
reminding you to make this november
rovenberg
check out the new midas touch rovember
t-shirt collection at
store.midastouch.com
that's
store.midastouch.com hurry up and get
your rovember t-shirt before they sell
out let's go
you